if I were born 10 years later you know but for
the grace of God there's no doubt in my mind
that I would have transitioned I got really
involved in like feminism about like 10 odd
years ago I think what sucked me into it in the
first place was this kind of revelation of like
everything is socially constructed and it became
quite clear to me that it's just like no that's
not the case the fact that I was autistic getting
diagnosed was what helped me there is there is a
link I think it's something like 40 percent
yeah yeah yeah your transition are autistic
yeah yeah why are we talking about this letting
children do whatever they want is not kind no and
it might make you feel like you're doing the
kind of thing and the whole society can tell
you it's kind but what we're doing now is like
the least kind thing that can never be done to
you
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm Francis
Foster I'm Constantine and this is a show for you
if you want honest conversations with Fascinating
People our fantastic guest today is somebody you
have not seen on the podcast circuit she's in
fact the first person that we ever hired to
work with us here at trigonometry she edits most
of the videos that you guys see and she has a very
interesting story to tell about some of the things
that we talk about regularly on the show Sophie
Spital welcome to trigonometry thank you it's nice
to be here bit weird but yeah a bit weird to be on
on the other side of the camera exactly uh it's
great to actually have this conversation you've
been building up to it for a long time we'll get
into the stuff that you want to talk about and we
want to ask you about before we do though what has
been the journey that's taken you to be sitting
here because you were the first person we hired
as I said you emailed us saying hey do you you
know are you looking for anybody and it kind of
took off from there but what's been your journey
through life yeah um yeah well I I come from
Chelmsford in Essex that's what I was born I moved
to Brighton which is um for anyone who doesn't
know it's like the Portland Oregon of the UK so
it's a very very Progressive place um I got really
involved in like feminism about like 10 odd years
ago um because I was trying to do the right thing
at the time it was it was that kind of um liberal
feminism of that sort of in sectional it's totally
different from the family and she met us yeah
um but yeah so I was really involved with that um
and I would have considered myself at that point
woke like I actually like I've found diary
stuff from that time and I actually did call
myself woke it was like not a pejorative just
actually you know and I was proud of it and I
was very like into that Progressive stuff and
then well long story short on that one I I got
very disillusioned with it when I saw that it
didn't actually marry up with like reality and
there was a bit there were some good good seeds
seeds of Truth in there but I moved away from that
um but I was really really passionate about
the truth and doing the right thing and doing
what's good and right in the world um and
that's kind of why I never really kind of
make fun of or you know I don't think people are
stupid on the other side because I'm like I know
a lot of them are really well-meaning and a lot
of them they just they want to be they want to do
the moral right thing in their lives and that
was what was giving me at the time um anyway
so I I then I got um really into listening to
uh Douglas Murray who's the gateway drug to um
basically leaving behind a lot of the letters and
I had at the time I was really passionate about
um yeah getting to the truth and I just saw these
people that a lot of people had been on the show
um speaking this truth that I realized
it just wasn't wasn't marrying up with
what people said about what these people are
like these people are evil racist bigots and
I was like well if I actually listen to what
they say that's not the case and so I kind
of flipped from being on the far left to being
um well not on the far right yeah I'm not sure
legitimate right um
I go to extremes and I've been finally finally
finding my place on on that stuff anyway but then
so I started listening to a lot of this stuff
and then um I found trigonometry um in during
the lockdown actually the first lockdown um and
I was just like someone said my friend Ruth was
like oh just check this out I think you'll like
this and I looked through the feed and I was like
oh my gosh it's like all the people I love and
listen to and so um got hooked on that and then I
messaged you guys being like you know hey can is
there anything I can do to help and unbeknownst
to me at that time young sweet Anton who's the
producer um was completely um inundated with
stuff and and so I I stepped in and pretty much
took over from there you absolutely did and look
actually the thing that we want to talk to you
about isn't wokeness necessary but I was curious
that you said that you were obviously we've talked
about this before she's spilling water on herself
she's got coffee and Classics though um yeah
you were talking about the fact that you were
in this kind of liberal feminist mindset yeah
and then you mentioned that it didn't marry up
to reality which is what sort of shook you out of
that to some extent yeah what was it that made you
think that it didn't marry up to reality like
what were some of the conf the clashes between
reality and ideology that you experienced
yeah uh good question um there was a lot of
stuff like I think what sucked me into it in the
first place was this kind of revelation of like
everything is socially constructed so for example
you look at things people come to you and they say
um well why do we have blue as the boy coloring
pick for the girl color and you go oh yeah they're
just arbitrary colors they you know but we've
assigned this to them and then a lot of stuff was
you see stuff and I still see it online about
like children's clothes and it's like all the
boys clothes are like building and fighting and
you know triumphing all the girls clothes are
like be kind you know be sweet lovely um and
at the time The Narrative was everything is
socially constructed so there's no difference
between men and women's at all it's literally
just how we socialize them in society and I
really bought into that even to the extent
where I didn't believe that there was such thing
as someone being subjectively beautiful like I
remember arguing with someone being like are you
anything she's beautiful because you know you've
been socialized that way and all this kind of
stuff really yeah legitimately um so I was like
online in in line with the thinking you even like
the kind of thinking you see now which is like
no disrespect but people being like obese with
a shaved head and like loads of piercings but
saying like I'm I'm a tent and I'm just as
attractive as this person who just don't
understand it because you've been you know anyway
but uh but the crap so sorry to interrupt yeah
you know what that makes your point so well
about you know the people on the other side
of there is such a thing yeah uh are not stupid
because you're an incredibly smart person uh and
well you're very intelligent but for you to
believe something that factually incorrect is
quite incredible right because our standards of
beauty are based on biology yeah yeah ratio and
yeah all of that Symmetry and all of that yeah so
it's it's so interesting that that you could have
been persuaded to think that yeah yeah yeah
well the thing is I'm a bit of an all-nothing
person and so when I was saw the seed of this
I jumped into it I started seeing everything
through that lens and actually um quite quickly um
because I went into it Full Throttle like I I saw
the Fort Smith very quickly as well because you
know just like it it's a sort of a blessing and a
curse because it kind of means that I can throw
myself into something and I can be in it like
fully in it and then see the problems like very
quickly as well um but yeah so I started to see
how this just doesn't marry up with reality
and I started to understand well actually
you know there are reasons I started learning
a little bit more about the differences like
between men and women like neurologically um and
you know in terms of our bodies and everything
and it became quite clear to me that it's just
like no that's not the case and again even with
the thing about as I said School uh sorry not
school clothing in like shops it's the message
that you get at the time was you know boys and
girls are blank slate and we've socialized girls
to be into flowers and pretty things and the
boys into this but the reality is is that the
market is following the response the market isn't
interested in like churning out like strong boys
and and weak girls or whatever the market is just
following up people like and yes there is probably
an element well there's definitely an element of
um girls get socialized into it because that's the
majority thing but it's also like the reason that
you know if they started you know putting loads of
um if they put them boys clothes stuff on a lot of
the girls clothes stuff um you know when they're
old enough to choose their own they're not going
to choose it they are the girls are more likely
to choose the the kind of princess dress over the
Spider-Man outfit like you know most most girls
um so yeah I just realized this is it's more
complicated than that than what I'd initially
thought and there are other things for you Sophie
you've always been a fascinating person to me
have one of the things that I really enjoy
talking with you yeah about with you is
autism being neurologically atypical when
did you realize that you were autistic and
you saw the world in a different way yeah well
that was around well actually I always kind of
knew it because I had sensed it in many ways
actually funnily enough a lot of the things
I've discovered about autism I had no idea
we're connected to autism at the time when
I got diagnosed so I was diagnosed when I was 25
so that's um so that's 2015. it's not actually um
it's not actually that uncommon to get diagnosed
that late in life you know for most girls actually
is that's changed now because people are thinking
about a lot more but most women who are diagnosed
were diagnosed in adulthood because they benefit
they manifest differently in terms of the boys
tend to kind of act out and have meltdowns in
a very like explosive in school and the girls
are just kind of like I like rules and just like
working and like high Achievers and so I was like
that I was like all the way through school it's
like achievement you know and I did my school my
you know college uni and then um but the problems
didn't really arise until after uni because
um everything happened to that point was
very structured and then you finish uni
and it's like I literally have the entire world
of choices and I don't know what to do and like
the paralysis of that um and other problems that
I had with not being able to respond to change
executive functioning skills so life management
skills um just got me to a place of complete
um breakdown really like I literally like just
not not being able to function in the world
and I was very ashamed of that because
at the time I didn't know it was autism
so I just thought I don't get it like I'm really
high achieving and get get high grades and you
know a good degree and everything but I can't
like do the washing up and I know you know and
a lot of that's through sensory issues and as well
um but yeah so there was a lot of shame that I had
attached to that and for other reasons which
we'll go into but but yeah the warning signs
are always there but it is the black and white
thinking and the kind of really extreme thinking
um you know which you know leads you to sometimes
call me an extremist but also as well I mean you
told that story from your PE lesson and obviously
tell it because you're going to tell it a lot
better than me when it comes to identification
and gender ID so yeah yeah yeah yeah so yeah so
another part of um my experience let's just set
the context a little bit Yeah because I think the
issue that we've talked a lot about on the show as
you well know is how I do I mean and this is why I
asked you about wokeness because it it just shows
you how ideology is so powerful yeah that it can
convince you even a very smart person like you and
like me and like everyone really of things that
are just patently not true yeah but ideology is
a very powerful thing and one of the things we've
talked a lot about on the show is the the rise in
transgenderism and young children in particular
identifying out of their gender and so on yeah
how that marries up to you know a lot of the other
stuff particularly in relation to autism I mean
there's there's a clear link yeah people who are
autistic and people who are transitioning and a
lot of people essentially are making the argument
that the overwhelming majority of the increase
in recent years is um basically autistic and gay
children yeah sort of looking for an answer to
why they're different yeah and ending up in this
new thing yeah and the reason we wanted to have
you on is that that is actually to some extent
your experience so yeah tell us tell us that yeah
now that we've said that up yeah yeah yeah yeah
um yeah it's weird I'm about to tell my story to
however many people um but yeah yeah two yeah the
cameras are off um yeah I I always experienced
thinking that I was a boy from a young age
um and it's hard to explain what that means
because it's like what what does that mean
um like and it wasn't that I wanted to be a
boy or like I was telling people well I'm on
board I'm actually a boy I actually genuinely
thought I was um because and I didn't realize
um that I was a girl until something would
come along and remind me so I think what
you were referring to maybe Francis was
yeah like I think when I was in assembly
in primary school so I don't know how
old it was maybe like five or something
um and the teacher asked us asked everyone about
no so the teacher asked the boys specifically a
question and I started answering and I just
remember the boys next to me being like why
are you answering you're a girl and I was
like oh yeah I'm a girl yeah you've got to
remember that gotta remember that um and it was
kind of like that all the way like I default
into thinking that I was male and that other
people saw me as male um and that carried on all
the way through my life really pretty much until
well until some stuff happened later that you
know has alleviated that but but yeah like I had
that all the time like um and even when I was like
25 like um my friends um I had my hair
cut and my friends are like oh you know
you should get some lipstick um because
at the time I I don't think I'd really
worn makeup apart from when I've been
forced to for a special occasion but
um I didn't like you know girls
stuff at all I was completely like
I was just always with the boys and I was just a
massive tomboy and I didn't like that stuff anyway
um yeah my friends were like oh let's get you some
lipstick and they sort of marched me down to Boots
and um I mean obviously I love lipstick now I love
it now like it's actually it's quite fun it's like
a little sort of coloring in book at the start of
the day every day which is fun for me but like the
we went there they they put the lipstick
on me and I just genuinely felt like just
really like ashamed because I just felt
well I felt like a clown first of all
um and then when I walked home wearing the
makeup I was just like expecting everyone to
look at me like you know like you know because
I thought that they were seeing a man the way
people might look at a man wearing yeah exactly
and I thought that they were they would see a man
walking down the street in drag so I thought
I'd draw like you know stairs but then I had
to remind myself oh no you're a woman and so
they're seeing a woman wearing lipstick which
is normal for them and so like and that was the
same when I was 25 before I was diagnosed so
um that was kind of my story all the way through
life and and it wasn't the done thing back in
those days too especially not for girls to um do
anything about it because you don't you just you
just say I'm a tomboy and I'm comfortable with
these things and I just carry on also there's no
like the reason why um up until very recently with
the whole explosion of girls identifying as trans
it was pretty much all boys and I think the reason
for that one of the reasons for that is that
there's no socially safe way for a boy to sort
of [Music] um gender bend as it were like for me
I just wore shorts and t-shirts and whatever so I
could wear boys clothes but it didn't look like I
was cross-dressing whereas if you're a little boy
and you you hate being a boy and you want to be a
girl you know you you'll start wearing dresses and
then you know you're gonna very quickly it's gonna
be evidence to everyone around you that there's
some incongruity going on there and Sophie did
you feel apart from this one instance with the
makeup did this cause you particular distress
did you feel a sense of discomfort or disgust for
your own body which is what some people talk about
um well actually interestingly I feel like the
pressure almost like in terms of fit in with
the narratives to say yeah I I really you know
had a problem in my body I actually I actually
didn't I had because when you when you don't
have a choice to opt out of your gender as
so many teenagers are given the choice now you
just get on with it and you know realistically
speaking there's not too many moments in
one's life where your sex actually comes
into play and so you know you learn to use the
bathroom with this symbol on it the lady symbol
um and that's it really and and when
people referred to me as women it
was just a little reminder oh yeah I
mean there was a bit of a there was
it did hurt not being able to join in with the
boys and like so I explained when I talk about
gender dysphoria now which is what it is you
know it's the it's defined as the persistent
discomfort and distress associated with your
your sex I think that's the right definition
um when I yeah when I experienced that I talk
about in in terms of like two separate categories
there's there's the actual thinking I was a boy
and then there's the wanting to be so as I the
wanting to be wasn't there when I was young but
when I got older and I would have a reminder that
I'm a woman I would then have feelings of my
life would be so much better if I were a man
and everything would be I don't know like I just
got really annoyed with the seemingly arbitrary
things that were foisted on me as a girl to to
that seem to be valuable to other people like in
terms of looking after your appearance or whatever
like um I mean like I have to wash my face every
morning yeah yeah yeah no but seriously it's
just like I mean like I didn't like wash my hair
do my hair and I've talked about it before and I
feel I think my mum feels quite bad about it but
and you know she basically said to me I when
I was like 13 or something like you need to
start washing your hair and if you don't
wash your hair like I will cut the whole
lot off and because it had genuinely got to the
stage of being like matted and horrible and and
I was just so not bothered about that stuff
and I saw it such a waste of time and such a
stupid imposition that I just I just couldn't
care less anyway she did cut all my hair off
about that um
you know that she's an evil mother but I think it
was the right thing to do to be honest because it
did make me back up my ideas a little bit um but
uh but yeah so so there were um sorry there were
like uh those those feelings but I think one of
the interesting things is I see a lot of people
who are going through gender dysphoria online
talking about their hatred for their bodies
but I was different in that I I never thought
about my body like I don't think I realized
I had a body till I was like 23 or something
um which is obviously that's a little bit um
exaggerated because of course you know you have
a body but what I mean is I never thought about
it like you know I probably thought about my body
about as much as you think about your capillaries
do you mean like I know they're there or
or maybe like choose something that you
can actually physically see like I don't know
the crook of your elbows and things like I
know it's there I can see it but I never
think about it and I didn't think about
um yeah so I actually you know contrary to
yeah what a lot of people kind of experience
with their sort of hatred of the body I was
just completely disassociated from it and I
actually so I had the blessing of never being in
any way dissatisfied with my body because I just
never thought about it so I was just like
it's working it's functioning it's fine do
you think that's part of the problem now is
because of social media and gender ideology
that kids are now being encouraged and in
fact it could be argued manipulated into
an obsession with their own bodies yeah yeah
yeah yeah I mean like I'm showing my age but
we didn't really have social media when
I was growing up back in the day um yeah
um yeah so we didn't really have social media
so it was there wasn't that fixation on I mean
girls around me were always kind of uh you know
especially in school the girls were like you know
doing their hair and makeup and stuff but I mean I
actually yeah I think I I developed quite a lot of
um sexism really against women because of because
of that because I didn't understand the value of
it and I yeah they always think they were vain
or something yeah yeah like I had a I had when
I was working through so I obviously we will come
to like how because you know basically there was
an alleviation of my gender dysphoria um due
to we'll get there yeah we'll get there but
but yeah I realized that because of the autism
and my black and white way of thinking there
just wasn't any space for like um there wasn't
any space for nuance autists don't do Nuance I
mean I try really hard to do it now because like
I care so much about the truth and the truth is
nuanced and so you have to like I have to actively
go against and type to really really work on that
because it's important to me but I basically just
looked at the girls were like like you know why
would you rather play with a Barbie than an action
man an action man AB sails and shoots missiles and
you know does cool stuff you know rock climbing
and where and and the Barbie is literally just
standing there with like a mirror and I was
just like and so it blew my mind that other
girls would choose this and you know like now
as I say with a bit of nuance I understand that
you know dolls and things like that are very good
like um social tools for learning many things as
um and they're very very useful and there's
nothing wrong with choosing a Barbie but at
the time I just had so much disdain for girls
and that made me disassociate even further to
the point where I didn't even consider myself one
of them and so I had when I was working through
trying to get over my gender dysphoria I met with
one of the um pastors of my church um Stephen and
he you know I were talking about and I was like ah
like word I don't want to be a woman women are so
um boring and just airheaded and all they care
about is their appearance and you know like I
know I'm I'm really like um passionate about like
philosophy and and history and all these important
intellectual things and you know and they just
they're just not on my level and he was like
yo you're being really sexist you need
to repent um genuinely and I was like
that Ridge just really hit me because I was just
like yeah I am I'm being sexist and what I've
done is I'd conflated all of the worst things I'd
seen about um this sort of picture of femininity
I built up in my mind to almost making an enemy so
if you've got an enemy you can run away from it or
fight it or whatever um and then I just realized
that I mean obviously that was sexist I'm and
I'm being a bit over the top about it but so but
yeah I had to work through that because I realized
that there's just so many that's so not true and
like some of the things that I had a problem with
adjust women just being women in the same way that
a lot of people have problems with the things that
are masculine and they're just you know it's
just men being men a lot of the time and it's
like it's not it's just it's just that I was an
outlier on the bell curve that I resented that
this episode is brought to you by better help
Constantine what's the best thing about having
this episode sponsored by betterhelp in my
country mental health is something that you
have before you start drinking thankfully
it will start drinking at breakfast so we
have no problem really yes our slogan is drink
breakfast vodka and become real men okay but
if you do want to feel better inside and out
then maybe you should try better help I have
been doing therapy for over a year and it has
really helped me understand myself better and
become far more effective in both my work and
my personal life I always knew you were not a
real man pass me the Vodka therapy has helped me
transform myself so that I take responsibility for
my behavior and my attitude you can't achieve
your dreams if you don't think you deserve to
every shot you drink make you feel stronger what
is problem and the great thing about better help
is that it's all online and they can connect you
with their licensed therapist who can work with
you so that you can achieve your goals it takes a
few minutes to set up and it can fit around your
schedule I will never forget my first love Olga
orgasmachenko and the Beautiful relationship that
could have been and if it's not working for
you with a particular therapist then you can
always switch at no extra charge I am doomed to
become Russian poet discover your potential with
better help visit betterhelp.com trigger today
to get 10 off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash trigger I have run out of
breakfast Vodka it's time for lunchtime Brandy
so can we come back chronologically
a little bit because
um one of the narratives in the modern world
is that a lot of young people experience all
of these sort of feelings and thoughts around
puberty because that's when the shock of reality
of their biology comes in yeah I know it's an
intimate question but I think it's relevant to
this conversation you would have gone through it
did that not have an impact yeah literally not at
all like I don't remember when I started my period
I don't remember my body changing I don't really
literally I couldn't give you any insight
into that that's so interesting it was like
yeah I I have not one memory of thinking that that
is fascinating that is so interesting I think I
noticed I think once when I was in PE when I was
in high school I noticed that that I had hair on
my legs for the first time that's the only memory
I have yeah um okay well moving on then from the
hairy legs conversation uh I'm just curious
to um to to talk about the link with autism
yeah because this is something you've done a lot
of looking into how how do these things connect
yeah yeah well this is the thing I think a lot
of people people know now that it does connect
yeah I think several years ago I was tearing my
hair up because I was just like finding out about
how the the fact that I was autistic getting
diagnosed was what helped me to which was
which helped me to heal really from genders
for it maybe not here wasn't the right word
but like it alleviated it as I understood my
autism because it just explained it all and
um yeah so I was looking into um when I found
out I had autism when I got diagnosed I started
looking into the neuro science of it because
obviously autism is a neurodevelopmental condition
and so I started looking into neurodevelopment
um I read this brilliant book by um professor
Sir Simon Baron Cohen of Cambridge University he's
like the he's like the world leading uh Authority
on autism really or one of them but he's also like
um world leaning in cognitive sex differences so
the way men and women's Brains work differently so
he's about five minutes away from getting cancer
that's true enough yeah um so uh I was reading
his book he wrote a book called The Essential
difference which um if it was brought out if it
all brought out 10 years ago probably would have
been to under stretch but it was about I think
it's about 20 years old now but he basically
literature on the differences between the way men
and women think into this you know very readable
book and I'd recommend anyone to read it but um
one of the things that I learned in that book
um was um the differences between men and
women in terms of what's called empathy
empathizing and systematizing skill sets
and so like this is kind of this is just
putting a scientific label on what we already know
which is that generally speaking the majority of
men are more interested in things and Concepts
and systems and like problem solving and that
and the majority of women are less interested
in that and more interested in uh the kind of
um emotional side of life uh relationship
building looking after children nurturing
um building that kind of thing and so yeah I
think summed up really it's that most men are
more interested in things and most women
are more interested in people and those
those are the bell curves and obviously there's
outliers which will come back to but anyway so
um then I learn about the the extreme male brain
theory of autism because the amazing thing that
you know that you know the combining is two
fields of autism and cognitive sex differences
is that if you look at the uh brain of someone
with autism their brain is like an exaggerated
version of the male brain right so um really
high systematizing really low empathizing
um and um that's that's the same for men and
women I mean I've got a little graph that I can
put up but it shows the the differences that
you know you've got the men and the women the
the men are less empathic and the women are
more empathic but they're quite similar and
then down the other end you've got um really
unempathic uh men and women with autism anyway
um obviously to learn that the autistic brain
is like a male brain on crack you know started
to answer my questions because
I think at that before that I'd
thought there was something wrong with me you
know like I was I was deeply ashamed because
I I felt like a failure as a woman before which
was one of the reasons I ran away from it because
I had such low levels of empathy I'm in like
the second percentile for compassion so you
know 100 people in a room there's like
one person with less compassion than me
um and that's way lower than the average
for a male um let alone a female and so
I'm a Christian as you well know
the top level Chrizzo as you call me
and for me one of the really important things to
do is to love people and to to be loving and and
I think I again like that's probably why I got
involved with feminism because at the time I was
like I want to fight I want to do the right thing
I want to you make the world better for women
um but yeah so this injunction to be loving
was so important to me but I didn't feel
loving feelings right because I didn't have
these compassionate empathic feelings and
I was surrounded particularly in
the church with loads of amazing
um compassionate like pastoral women and they
were just and I just felt nothing you know
and so I felt really deeply ashamed of that but
then when I so I thought I was defective I thought
I was a failure really as a woman and then when
I started learning about the extreme male brain
stuff I was like well like I'm autistic I'm
not I'm not you know I realized that I was just
um I wasn't a man you know I realized that I was
a just a rarer type of woman um and and that was
the key really that just unlocked everything you
know because I mean it was gradual it was like
the key turned and then the door opened really
slowly um because I yeah I did move quite slowly
into appreciating that but it it started to
explain everything because I was like well okay
um I don't need to I I was I did try I went for
a few years of trying really hard to sort of
be what I thought a woman should be um in terms
of I try some of it stood me in good stead now
in terms of like helping people but I I I took a
lot of like lessons and training and like pastoral
care and so like I can I know the right things to
do like if someone is in distress or like I'm not
you know if someone is grieving or stuff so I
I've learned actually a lot of practical skills
it doesn't mean their feelings there but anyway um
another one of my elders or you know pastors same
thing at church really helped me with that because
before I was diagnosed with autism I went to him
and I was saying you know I I feel really bad
because I haven't got these loving feelings and I
want to be loving and I want to you know you know
following Jesus footsteps and you know love people
um but I don't feel these feelings and he said
you know like um you know that he basically said
your um perhaps you could be the one person in
a room where there's like a crisis and everyone
else is overwhelmed by their emotions and you
know you know but you can be like see through
it and you know be like really um helpful in
that situation and just use your gifts and and
uh yeah that really helped me that really
stuck with me because I realized that
that yeah I was I was trying to you know I
was trying to be the opposite of what I was
um and now I see actually that the
love primarily isn't about feelings
um like any parent knows or you know the
apparent but you're a teacher um I think
you mentioned it once or twice um and also isn't
your mum from Venezuela exactly yeah nailed it
um yeah what was I say so you is it love isn't
necessary yeah it's about actions I'm guessing
well not even necessarily like you can this
is a problem I think that we really just
kind of messed up with over the last few years
that we we think to be loving to someone is to
just go along with everything they want and
you know like if you're a loving parent and
your child wants like chocolate like just
before bedtime or whatever you just say no
you can't have that and that's being loving
in the moment um and they feel like yo you
hate me or whatever like you want me to die you
know and but it's just like you actually know
what's best and what you're doing is loving and
you're the but I think at the moment we are so
I think that the I'm one of the only values
that we that we kind of hold to in this kind of
sort of [Music] post-christiany sort of fade
failing liberal kind of Western project is one of
the only things we have is be kind we just have to
be kind and nice and that's how we know we're good
people and I think because we everyone wants to
be good I think I think most people care about it
they want to be good they want to be on the right
side of history and what they're told now is the
loving good thing to to be is to be kind is to be
really kind and so but isn't tempered by truth and
you know I think so let's hear some criso
stuff just pre-warning but like the Bible says
of Jesus that he was full of grace and truth
and I think that the Western project is only
um flourished in as much as it's held to those
that christly balance of grace and truth I want
to say grace I mean like you know Grace compassion
Mercy tenderness um we need it's it's nice to show
Grace to someone but you also need to do the
right thing and the thing that is true your
point is letting children do whatever they want is
not kind no and it might make you feel like you're
doing the kind of thing and whole of society
can tell you it's kind but what we're doing
now is like the least kind thing that can ever
be done to children and um I often think about
this with pronouns because like um if I were born
10 years later you know but for the grace of God
there's no doubt in my mind that I would have
transitioned that I would have gone the whole hog
and that's the thing about autistic people is like
we go the whole world if you notice yeah um just a
little bit it's just like I got into Star Trek and
like two weeks later I bought like a full uniform
um and like that's just that's just me but
that's just autists like that's what we're
like and and and and you know there's some duty to
that and some craziness but going the whole hog um
I would have done that with transition I would
have had a mastectomy I would have you know it
would have been it just wasn't a solution at the
time but like I look back at that I'm just like
I can't believe that
I can't believe that we're going to we've gotten
to a place in society where we think oh it's okay
like that that's the loving thing to do just
give them what they want um when their children
the literary children the brain doesn't finish
developing until like 25 anyway but to to give
you know puberty blockers and and you know medical
intervention to children it's just like absolutely
insane it's like how do we get to this place and I
do think it's this lack of of like truth and like
the the value of like freedom and being loving
just didn't seems the ultimate value and why do
you think as well because I think there must
be another reason I accept your point I think
that's a major part of it but the link between
Autism yeah and gender dysphoria why is it that
we that we are not looking into that why are we
not studying that because that look that is that
there is there is a link I think it's something
like 40 yeah yeah yeah the transition are autistic
yeah yeah why are we talking about this the the
hot the figures are scary like the Tavistock like
the CQC report on the the Tavistock the jits
clinic for the for child gender uh transition
um is like 50 had autism or um ADHD which
is very similar in some ways um there's also
a report an article written by two of the
previous kids members of staff that say
that 50 of their like they did a strategic
sort of analysis and 50 of them autistic
um there are so many reasons why it's um
such an appealing Prospect to autistic people
um yeah one of them is yeah like obviously on
the female side of things you've got that kind of
yeah that neurological shift to the male Direction
so of course all your interests are going to be
similar to your male peers all of everything you
see like everything that's expected of you which
is kind of again as I say it's it's natural and
it's based on the it's based on the majority like
everything we have in society is based on the
majority so it's like um if you're an outlier
that's that's going to affect you badly but so
uh I think Francis question was more about why is
it that we don't look at this obvious thing that
staring Us in the face yeah as a society dealing
with this issue yeah and we're not going well look
if autism is let's say it's a comorbidity yeah
is that maybe something we should look at maybe we
should yeah you know yeah think about that yeah do
you see what I mean yeah 100 um the only thing I
was just going to say about the uh the other side
of it which is the boys thing is that because you
could say oh well the boys are getting an extreme
male brain so surely there should be more manly
but there's so many other things that come along
with autism that are that are going to affect you
in terms of your social impairment like if you are
um if you're just socially delayed and and autism
is a delaying thing you know like I was like the
last in my class to learn to read I was um yeah
say I didn't know about my body until there's
you know my 20s I I I didn't um yeah I didn't
make a friend until like I was 10 or something
um so um there's there's that delay and if you've
got that delay in your and you're a boy and you're
gonna be socially less confident as well and the
girls would tend to uh make friends of you more
like the autistic guys I know you know like they
most of their friends are girls because they're
more accepting of your quirks or your your your
own coolness or whatever and so they take you
under their wing in a way um and so you kind of
get on the boy side um why don't we recognize it
as a problem in society I mean we are saying oh
it's one of the many comorbidities you say oh you
know a lot of people um who are transgender they
are some you know a lot of them are you know ADHD
or a lot of them have autism but it's just like we
have totally neglected to understand that there's
a difference between having a comorbidity
and something being the cause of something
um so like there was a study in 2019 um
would that [__] that showed that of
um what was it of those who identified as trans
and non-binary 42 met the criteria for an Autism
diagnosis um and you know obviously the normal
rate of autism in the general population is
about two percent so um and Dr stack who led the
study was like you know I don't know if he was a
a whistleblower so to speak more probably just
following the outcome of his study but was just
like we need to be screening people for autism
anyone who comes in to ask about gender stuff and
yeah as I say the tragic thing is that we haven't
looked into it but I think I know the reason why
we've been so rubbish at looking into [Music] um
all of the comorbidities and problems and causes
I mean like if you look at the like the stats on
the Tavistock from Hannah Barnes book um time to
think which is excellent piece of Journalism um
the stats are just terrifying it's like 2.5 or
something of the intake didn't have any kind
of major like um issue with uh like abuse or
um uh yeah neurodivergence or I think 25 of
them have been in care compared to 0.67 of the
population like a lot of them had had they were
like 10 times more likely to have experienced
um abuse like sexual abuse I think um there are
all these things like the self-harm there's OCD
there's there's all these different things and
they weren't looked up I think I know the reason
um and the reason is like well I I split Society I
split life as we know it history into two eras so
I think there's the era of old trans and the era
of new Trans and the era of old trans goes up to
about 2017 I'd say around that period and then
new the year of new Trans is everything after
that and these are two wildly different uh ways of
looking at the trans experience so up until 2017.
um the way that we thought
of the trans experience was
like if you it wouldn't have been like because I
lived in Brighton as I say I live in Brighton and
you would sometimes see a fellow in a dress ten
years ago 15 years ago and but if you'd spoken to
him at the time and you said like um oh you know
why why are you wearing a dress he might say well
I know I'm a man but like I feel more comfortable
in women's clothes and I've always related to
women and I always you know I've always identified
with women um but then when the shift happened
around 2017 people went from saying that they
identify with women so I identify it as a woman
and so we went from saying I feel like something
to I am something and the repercussions of that
that little shift affect literally everything like
it is all the entire problem that we have now is
all down to the shift and I can give you Myriad
examples but like the so I mean we had Marcus
Evans on the show a whistleblower from the
Tavistock he'd been there for like 35 years
um you know consultant psychotherapist I think and
he said you know like in the old days or you know
before this big shift and everything if someone
comes in saying you know I'm really distressed you
know like I I feel like trapped in the wrong body
or whatever the treatment pathway for them was
exploratory therapy so it's like um let's
look at your life in the round let's look at
um you know your relationship with your
parents relationship with your peers
um has there been any abuse any trauma um
what are your expectations what actually
means to be a man or a woman in the
world you know talk us through that
um and all these different things and
they explore those things but when this
new kind of way of thinking of saying it's your
identity and it's who you are rather than just
feelings that you have came in you can't do that
anymore because if your gender is who you are um
and you it's not that you feel like a boy you
can't treat something that you are yeah quite
yeah I mean it's like it because it would be
transphobic it'd be like or it would be like
someone with Down Syndrome going to the doctor
they don't try to cure your Down syndrome or then
try and cure you of being black it's just like I
mean like um because it's it's that would be okay
well no it's not even your identity it's who you
are it's intrinsic to your so this is the thing so
like there's in the old days it was seen as again
the reason I'm giving this 2017 cutoff point is
because uh something strange happened there I
think it might be to do with people needing to
shore up their sense of being a good person in the
wake of brexit and Trump very very polarizing year
2016 and people were desperate to kind of I think
no commits themselves and others that they're on
the right side and this was the thing that came
along and and you have certain things that came
along around that time like India Willoughby
former guest of the show was on Celebrity Big
Brother in 2018. I'm a real woman Amanda I want
you to know that yes a real woman okay I'm glad
that sinking here I'm going to say one more time
so it really penetrates I am a real woman okay
and then obviously around that time you see the
emergence of the phrase like trans women are women
and and so and in fact if you think about it when
was the last time you heard someone say identify
as a woman they don't do it anymore they don't
even say that anymore so it so it identifies these
women dropped so so now it's it's who you are and
as I say so once yeah I thought so when I read
time to think the the book about the Tavistock
I thought I had this idea in my head that
the kids are coming along to the Tavistock being
referred and there must be some like it it can't
just be that they rubber stamped them and said
oh you know PB blockers there's adults in the
room it's all not the way that people say in the
media it's all being properly located you would
think that because you're like this is a place
of clinicians it's on the NHS it's it's being
overseen there's no way and you read the book and
you're like oh flip it actually was like that like
there was so much intervention from from like
mermaids and other like politicized bodies and
such a culture of fear um that they were literally
just being like okay uh well they had this thing
called this model called gender affirming care
which is um you know an orwellian sort of uh uh
twisting of words really because you know
it's like you know to really affirm someone
it would be to say you're you're brilliant just
the way you are and you don't need to change it
then you don't need to try and fit into these sex
stereotypes and you know you go for it but anyway
so this affirming care which comes in with
this idea of it's who you intrinsically are
um that just made everything a problem it's sort
of solidified it and it became the gold standard
not just the gold standard of care but like the
American Psychological Association and all these
top bodies said this is the way to care and if
you're not doing that if you're just exploring
it like in the old days you're kind of casting
down their problems sorry you're casting down
on their identity and who they intrinsically are
and it's not that they've got a problem they've
just discovered the truth of who they are um and
but but this this problem this shift from I feel
like to I am this old Trends where thinking this
neutrons we're thinking has affected everything
else as well so it's not just um you know autistic
and gay and other vulnerable children being
um treated because of this um you know
in my mind a massive medical Scandal
um and medical neglect but it's also um we see
it in every area like in terms of women's spaces
um because again it's like old trans you've
got a man who you know he feels like a woman he
feels comfortable moves clothes fine but it's not
going in the women's change rooms because he's not
entitled to he's not a woman but now it's like
well he is a woman and therefore you know he's
entitled to that that space and this is why this
is why I think people a lot of people just think
I don't get this trans argument like why can't
we just Live and Let Live and why can't they
just reconcile because it can't be reconciled
I'm so conflict of Rights it's a conflict of
Rights and so the only way that we can deal with
these problems is by going back just a few years
ago just what like seven eight years ago wherever
to you know live and not live wear what you want
call yourself what you want like that's fine I
don't mind I don't care like no one cares how
someone dresses and chooses to live their you
know Express themselves but I'm sorry we can't
overreach into the area of you actually are this
and we're just and but this is this is this is the
great news because um as I said before like the
I think the trans experiment has failed because
we are seeing all these dominoes fall when people
are suddenly realizing that the negative results
of what's happened hey KK Do You Believe In
Spring cleaning yes but only when my wife does
it in Russian men who clean up executed for not
being real men which is correct well for those
men who are living in the 21st century manscape
has an incredible offer for you manscaped are the
global leaders immense below the waist grooming
and have forever changed the grooming game with
their amazing performance package 4.0 inside
this care bundle you'll find their lawnmower
4.0 trimmer weed whacker ear and nose hair trimmer
crop preserver ball deodorant crop Revival toner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag to hold
your goodies this Elite trimmer is designed to
trim hair on loose skin although your huevos might
look like a couple of Boris Johnson's treat them
with respect and benefit from their proprietary
skin safe technology complete your grooming game
this spring with the new refined cologne signature
scent by manscaped this stuff is legit and we'll
have you smelling like royalty the good kind
not prince Andrew get 20 off and free shipping
with the code trigger 20 at manscape.com that's
20 off and free shipping with the code trigger
20 at manscape.com it's time to throw out all
your old hygiene habits and upgrade your life
people are suddenly realizing that the
negative results of what's happened because
um it started as I say 2017-18 started building up
online then we're going to lockdown everyone's in
their homes or online for a few years the real
world implications of this new Trans worldview
aren't manifested we come out of lockdown we try
to apply those that that new way of thinking in
the real world and it's an absolute catastrophe
in so many areas and so you see people starting to
backtrack and and like so in the last few months
we've seen like in terms of women's sports we've
seen great like changes in that in terms of like
World Athletics like World cycling World Aquatics
pardon me ooh deciding you know look we want
to be nice but at the end of the day we do
have to recognize that your body's you
know are different isn't talking about
male athletes and so they've said look we
don't want to discriminate but we're gonna
have an open category so it's going to be
female category and an open category so
um the you know the dominance Dominos has started
to fall in the sports area um you know we've seen
public backlash to the gender self-id stuff
like in terms of the double rapist that was
put in a woman's prison um uh in Scotland you know
caused this great you know people didn't realize
this was going on and again even someone like me
who's really involved in it I still had to say
I need to check the sources here and make sure
this is actually happening are actually men being
placed in women's prisons because I thought
that sounds like a sort of Daily Mail made-up
thing no disrespected anymore but you know it
sounds like one of these sort of like things
but you know I mean it sounds like a sort of
they're putting men in women's but they actually
are like around the world and they have been doing
so and and so there's been pushback on that this
um rapist has moved out of the women's
prison and that's you know that people
are calling for more of that that's
taking a turn that's taking a tumble
um then you've got like changing rooms and stuff
like Primark instituted gender neutral uh changing
rooms and then you know surprise surprise people
are coming on you know tick-tocks and I think
you're making great points by the way for real you
know and what you're saying is is true but don't
you think this says something deeper about society
as a whole yeah that we as a society have come
undone from our Mooring so to speak yeah where
we will say things like her penis yeah and no
one bats an eyelid yeah I mean to put it bluntly
that is mental yeah the thing is I understand
why you say it's mental but I don't actually
think it is mental because I think if you do
if you like as I said when I was a feminist before
if you accept that everything is a construct and
everything is up for being constructed then
because what they've done is they've said
we're going to expand the categories of of the
word man and woman they're not saying I think
people think oh someone's saying that someone can
become the opposite sex they're not saying that
they're literally just saying that the word woman
used to be you know like hogged by biological
women and now we're expanding it to what it truly
should be which is to include you know uh uh women
biological women and men who want to be women or
call themselves that I think the big problem here
comes from the invention of the concept of gender
itself well yeah um feminists don't like hearing
this because they're the one that popularized this
aspect of it but um it was kind of created as a
way of being able to opt out of femininity uh so
that you could say well I am a woman but I'm not
going to behave in the stereotypical ways that
women are expected to behave and I understand
the need or at least a desire to do that yeah um
but if you invent the concept of gender everything
else follows uh gender isn't a word that applies
to human beings I mean animals don't have gender
yeah right and neither do human beings but once
you create the idea that you can this can be a
difference between your sex and this other thing
yeah this is where you end up inevitable which
is why you say it makes perfect sense because it
makes perfect it does make perfect because if you
have gender then a woman can have a penis yeah I
absolutely yeah and so this is why I say to people
because I I do speak about this stuff and I try
and help people to understand it and I say like
I know I don't use the word gender because it
means different things to different people but
also because of what you said and I say to people
when you hear the word gender just replace it with
feelings because because that's what they are like
and so so what I was saying I so it used to be the
case that obviously sex and gender were synonymous
so if you had a form and it asked you for your
gender in the 70s you knew they're just meant sex
yeah like and so you you'd write male or female
but then as you say like it started to be used in
different ways and it started talking about your
roles and your expression and it's things like
that and I think there is some utility to that
um that there's also problems with it and then but
now as I say like if you add identity onto it and
you're saying it's it's an inherent like innate
thing about someone that they have an identity
sorry that they have like a sort of a gendered
soul as people have talked about um then then yeah
that that caused all these problems and so I was I
was chatting to the to the boys uh production boys
uh I was trying to work this out and I saying well
look if the word gender didn't exist at all right
but you wanted a word to explain what gender is
which is basically ultimately I think it's about
your feelings and how you fit in with your sex
that that is it really because it is it's it's
dependent on your sex like by definition because
it's it's in relation to your sex so it's like
um you know if you're transgender the idea is
that you there's a transition from you know your
sex so um so I said like if we didn't have the
word gender which is confusing so many people
because people think sex gender same thing and
we just use the word uh fitling as in how you
fit in and feelings and you just said I have a
fitling and everyone has a fitling right okay
so or t fitling if you want to pronounce your
t's but I'm from Essex so I don't pronounce
my t's but yeah so and if and if you said um you
know no form is going to ask you for your fitling
every former is going to ask you if it's relevant
for your sex and the word gender doesn't exist so
and then you come along and you say well you know
I really feel that I have a blue fitling or I have
a pink fluffy fitling it's like okay that's fine
but it doesn't affect anything whereas you know
it I think the reason it's so confusing is that
people actually think that because it's the word
gender which they they know and associate with
something that's real in their mind they can
they sort of it I think it confuses a lot of
ordinary people that um just do you see what
I mean absolutely it'd be so much easier if we
just got rid of the word gender well I know that
we can agree on that we can agree on unfortunately
uh it's now running rampant as it were it is the
monster that was created and now it's running
rampant yeah we are starting to see changes
positive changes I think we can all agree on what
else do we need to do because for me one of the
most worrying things as a former teacher everyone
can drink obviously is gender-neutral toilets in
schools when I saw this come in my head was in
my hands because I just thought these are people
who have no understanding about what it is like
to be a teenage girl going through puberty and
the vulnerability that these people these women
feel girls feel but yeah yeah I acknowledge that
most well girls feel some kind of vulnerability
when they are in puberty um very good impression
um we got a lot in common me and Grant um
yeah yeah no I I agree what can be done
yes well actually I while there's a lot of
mental stuff going on I'm actually incredibly
encouraged right now um I don't think I think
I have a very strong sense that this whole thing
is is coming crashing down right now I mean it's
because you haven't been to America Yeah well yeah
okay fine I know I know so obviously in America
it's different but we're very different I I know
and they've got this massive profit incentive that
we don't have over here and which is you know one
of the main reasons why I think that it's it's
continuing to go along there but I think people
are starting to push back and you know we are
seeing we've seen so many things this is like I
was talking about these dominoes falling or if you
want to think about it in terms of a Jenga block
you know like all these things are being pulled
out like you've got yeah like the Tavistock being
closed down and like the massive public shaming
of what happened at the Tavistock and everyone's
realizing it's such a a scandal and then you've
got over a thousand families suing the Tavistock
I don't even think I think you only saw about
ten thousand people in the last five six years
aren't they and like over a thousand families
are suing it and this is Britain it's like we're
not like an America where they just Sue anyone
at the drop of a hat you know we we're not
a litigious Society but a thousand families
suing the Tavistock very public lost coverage you
know like you know stories of like you know you've
actually seen mainstream newspapers like the times
and Telegraph Richie Herron a detransitioner had
his story um out Kira Bell like these these things
so that's that's one Jenga block we've had the the
self ID gender blocks taken away but people being
like it's mental and people normal people being
um mobilized as it were to to kind of get
together and and say actually we're not we're
not having this actually um and yeah as I say
that then you've got the sports thing you've got
the changing rooms what I was going to say before
about Primark is that they so many people came on
Tick Tock being like so I was just in Primark
um in Cambridge and um I feel really stupid
um yeah I was trying on some clothes and it
was a unisex changing room which I'm really
full and I love that because you know it
makes everyone feel included but twice
um two men walked opened the curtain walked
in on me um luckily both times I had I was
wearing footy clothes but I could easily not have
been um and I yeah it was two different people
um clearly from the same group and there was many
like probably like 100 changing rooms available
um so it's not like you know it was like always
someone in here or not it was you know clearly
um and both times like I was so shocked and I
was like oh sorry like as if it was my fault
um but yeah um I have to say that Primark have
been amazing um they were really really good
about it um yeah they have walked me back to
my car and everything because I was scared um
apparently it's not the first time it's happened
and um security are watching back the tapes and
seeing if they can find who it is but yeah I
just want to say to people please be careful
um and if you go to the changing room try not go
on your own um I will never be doing that again
I would rather take it home try it on and then
take it back and get refunded so yeah stay safe
so many people came on Tick Tock being
like crying and saying oh someone was
filming me and the changing rooms that
they did a u-turn and they reinstated
um you know Single Sex spaces for changing
all these things are falling into place and I
think we are going to come out of this in almost
like a dreamlike state in a few years being like
I can't believe that we let a very very small
minority of incredibly political voices just
yeah as you say run rampant and we thought well
you know they're Progressive and we want to be
Progressive and good people and if they seem to
know what they're doing and they've got degrees
in like gender Theory and queer Theory and
stuff and you know um I want to you know you
know I'm a liberal person and you know I love
gay people and you know and I don't care if
someone wants to wear a dress so you know people
think they Outsource their thinking of this and
they assume the experts especially someone like
the NHS they assume that they will be you know
competent enough and then you realize and like you
did a brilliant like Twitter thread in the video
about like why we've lost trust in institutions
turns out all these institutions just didn't have
you know the backbone or or all the principles
to stand on and this is why why I said before
well it comes back to the other thing you said
actually which is about uh children because you
talked about how it's all about kindness but what
you didn't mention is as part of the demonization
of men it's not actually about men it's about
what masculinity is and part of that is strength
and Authority which we fear more than anything
in modern society and to exercise strength and
Authority is seen as I mean quoting Jordan
Peterson here but it's seen as automatically
being conflated with tyranny right and so to say
to somebody well we understand that you have these
feelings but we are a medical profession we don't
just cut bits off children because it's not what
we do is a sign of tyranny it's a denial of your
identity it's a denial of medical treatment that
you need out of the kindness that we're supposed
to act with and so I think part of what you're
talking about societally where this comes from
is an unwillingness of people to essentially be
adults yes yeah yeah um I was thinking about this
yesterday um I think that Something's Happened
in the Millennium generation or slightly before
that maybe where we all kind of communally took
a puberty blocker and we literally like I think a
couple of decades we just decided I mean like the
the trans identifying thing is a way of opting out
of reality at the end of the day it's it's your
something about yourselves that you don't like
and you're trying to disassociate yourself from it
and I think that's what we've
done I think we've I think we saw
reality like life is difficult
I have to take responsibility
um and but we were given this kind of opt out of
adulthood and and that's where you get a lot of
adolescent adolescentish men who are kind of
your age um and you're not in this this camp
at all but it's like instead of like um instead
of uh the puberty blockers we've got like porn
and just weed and gaming and just casual sex
and like all the things we enjoy yeah indeed
so but you know I mean it's like we've there's
a way you can be that doesn't require you to
grow up and take responsibility and one of the
things about being a man is eventually getting
to a point where you have to be the authority
and it's very uncomfortable particularly if you
haven't been properly socialized to be in that
position yeah yeah I mean I you know the story
because I've told you but I was dreading hiring
not you specifically although you specifically
as well but just hiring anyone because I was
like we're going to have to manage this now
you don't really know how so I know I mean so
if we're running out of time so I before we go
to locals and we'll do a good chunk on there
for people because your your story actually
raised a lot of interest uh tell us very
quickly before we ask the last question but
very quickly about how you got peace with who
you are yeah yeah that's that's a good point
um I'm just very very grateful for people
in my life who you're welcome not your
um largely Christians actually who had what I um
talked about that that balance of Grace and Truth
um you know as a society we can go too far
towards you know Truth at the expense of of
being gracious and um and we have done that in the
past and Christian societies have done that in the
past you know if you look at sort of dickensian
Britain and you know it's just like you know if
the poor would rather die then they better do
it and decrease the Surplus population you know
um if anyone thinks I'm smart for knowing Dickens
that straight from Muppets Christmas Carol but you
know I mean it's like so we have done that and so
I'm not saying Christianity is perfect but that's
why I'm saying like if you do it right like and
so Christians are speaking to my life being like
doing what what the gender clinics were doing
back in the day which is exploratory therapy
and be like okay so there's a reality of who you
are and so it so it really helped me to be like so
I knew with the help of other people and with
the help of the scripture as well because I
that you know it was it's evident to me there's
just no concept of gender identity in the Bible
it's like you know you get amazing characters
like King David and he was like this amazing
King and he was also like he was a warrior but
he was also a poet and a musician and a harp
player and there's nothing in the Bible about
like well he was being really manly when he
was being a warrior and he was but he was
exploring his feminine inside it was just
like no he's just a man and so like you know
there was that but the kind of holding on to
Grace and Truth really really helped me um to
to come to peace in that because I realized that
I was a woman with a mind that was disconnected
from reality at times um so a woman
and so what an ending classic Francis but no I'm
just gonna say my mind needed to be brought into
alignment with the reality of my body as opposed
to a body that needs to be brought into alignment
of the reality of your mind and the Bible is
very skeptical of our feelings as being the
true north so in our society we're like your
feelings and yourself sense of identity is
like the main thing whereas the Bible always
like says the exact opposite it says that the
heart is wicked and deceitful above all things
and it can you know who can understand it and
now that is why that is why it must be canceled
now so uh it's great to have you on the show uh
please keep up the amazing work you're doing
obviously but uh as any guest on the show
you have one final question on before we go to
locals which is of course what is the one thing
we're not talking about the world it should
be [Music] um I think the whole trans thing
is a microcosm of a much broader problem so you
know you I was saying about just a failure to
bring us bring the truth and reality into
alignment with the way you want things
to be or the way you think the things
should be so the whole problem of the
the trans identifying you know movement
is I want my life to be like this I really
um or it should be like this like as I say when
I was a feminist it's like it should be like this
but reality always bites back um and so you're
always going to be at odds like with reality and
you're never going to find peace while you're
trying to live outside it I mean we've got a
whole world of social media telling you you can
you can you can you can well you can't and you
know the many detransition is a testament to that
and the people who've been betrayed by that but
I think it's a microcosm of a broader human
problem so like I think again like what I'm
saying about the US taking puberty blockets
like over the last best part of the century
um and Peter Hitchens writes
about this brilliantly in
um the rage against God brilliant book he
talks about how how have we gone from being
this kind of country with its massive Christian
Heritage and then suddenly like all of the
institutions and all the things of society and
that's all just Fallen away and he sort of charts
brilliantly like certain events that happen during
the last century that really kind of uh it's it's
kind of like you you know what you were saying
in your thread about how people lost trust in it
um in institutions the same thing happened
with Christianity over the course of uh you
know a few decades you know with the wars and the
sewers crisis and the female Affair and all these
different things um so the point is I think we
we said around the 60s given some of these crises
I think the world should be like this and
I don't like the reality of the way the
world is and I'm going to live in accordance
with that and then you see the sexual sexual
Revolution obviously which we've covered
with brilliant people like Louise Perry and
Mary Harrington just doing such a brilliant job
and Mary Eberstadt too yeah Mary Eberstadt yep
um top level Chrizzo um yeah loads of people um
have been writing about this now which is again
they tried the trans experiment it was so extreme
it's failing it's crumbling I think what we're
seeing now is what's happening in the wake of
that last best part of a century of just let's
do things our way let's completely reject God and
the way he says that things that life should be
ordered in accordance with thriving let's say that
you know let's throw out marriage let's throw out
um people taking responsibility for children let's
take let's throw out um you know sex is just you
know it's just a pleasure activity at the end of
the day and we should be able to have that and
placing that as the highest good in society the
highest value is like freedom and sexual you know
fulfillment and then the repercussions of that
you know Downstream are massive in terms of like
um you know people women's unhappiness in terms of
the Dayton Market trying to have sex like like men
as it were in terms of no strings attached and and
you know trying to be this empowered sexual being
when they don't inside a lot of them don't want
that they want to be with a man who's committed
to them and have a relationship and have children
and build a family and build a home in a community
that's what most women want and I think probably a
lot of men want as well um and then you've got you
know the other Downstream consequences which are
really sad like the like abortion and just like
if you if you say the highest value in society
is that I should be able to have sex whomever
I want and you know that's the most that's
the highest priority that's the highest value
then you know the it's almost like obligatory then
that a child's life should be sacrificed because
of that because it's like well that's that's my
right that's the most important thing comes before
responsibility and anything else so we're seeing
all these uh you know repercussions come out of it
um and I'm sure that many people will disagree
with me and that's fine I don't mind talking
and debating with anyone but what I'm saying
is we tried an experiment of rejecting God
I think and rejecting you know the the true the
inheritance of Christianity that had been brought
down over hundreds of hundreds of years and I
think that's failing in many ways but again in
the same way I'm encouraged about the the trans
thing failing I think I've seen a lot of people
interested in Christianity again and I think that
we've seen a lot of people talking about it more
freely and moribly and I think a lot of people
um interested in pursuing it in a way that they
weren't before and I've seen a lot of people
coming to Christ who have had completely
no background in it whatsoever
um and I think if you're if you'll
uh permit me to have one more minute
um the so I talked about the trans thing as a
microcosm of like what's happened over the last
century I think that is a microcosm of The Human
Experience the human problem which is um you know
if you if you want to look at history if you want
to look at the Old Testament the if you don't know
what the Old Testament is in the Bible pretty
much the story of the old the Old Testament is
um God's helps gives people like says this is
what you know this is what's good and right and
everyone's like yeah let's do it and then after
a while they're like actually you know we're
not going to do that they start doing their own
thing uh everything goes wrong they repent and
turn back to God and the cycle goes on and on and
on that's like the human problem and I think that
we're seeing that come around again there you
go Sodom and gomorrah's coming but it's going
to be fine after that yeah exactly if you give
your life to Christ after that look terrifying
anyway uh Sophie spittle thank you so much do
you want people to follow you online or yeah yeah
um just Twitter um probably um you
need to tell them yeah Sophie Spital
s-p-i-t-a-l like hospital without the ho
okay okay great uh follow us on locals
where we will continue the conversation
also I've got a Substack innit perfect
uh lemming Jr asks uh is there anything which can
persuade autistic people that
transitioning isn't the answer
thank you
foreign